- [Voiceover] Hello grammarians
today we're going to
be talking about the irregular plural.
Previously I had said that
if you take any English word,
any noun, say the word dog.
And you tack an s onto
the end of it like so.
Boop you get the word dogs
and that's how you form
the plural in all cases.
I was lying sorry, it turns
out that English is a little
bit more complicated than that.
While adding an s to things
is the way you usually
make things plural, sometimes,
there are other changes
and sometimes you don't even pluralize
using an s at the end.
But what we're not going
to talk about that now
that's for another time.
What I wanna talk about
today, is the most basic kind
of irregular plural, so we
have the difference in English
between regular and irregular plurals.
And remember a plural is when there's more
then one of something, it
comes from the latin plus.
Which means more.
As opposed to the singular
when there is just one
of something.
One dog, two dogs.
So there is a handful of words
in English and it really
is a handful, that don't
pluralize regularly.
Words like leaf and loaf and calf.
It's a baby cow.
If you try to pluralize these
as though they were regular
plurals you're gonna return
something that is not correct.
Or at least is not conventional
within modern standard
American English right so leafs
for example, unless you're
talking about the Toronto
hockey team, is not correct.
In fact, the proper term boop.
Is in fact leaves.
It is not loafs but loaves.
Tasty loaves of bread.
It is not calfs but calves.
So there are several different
kinds of irregular plurals
that's why this video is called part one.
But I'm only going to cover
one such irregular plural today
and that is the change from
singular f to plural v.
So if you see a word,
generally that ends in f.
The plural is going to become v.
You can learn anything David out.